hi there steve here again
i want to talk a bit about pronunciation
because it was a subject on a forum at
link lingq.com which is our language
learning community
and someone had posted a video of an
interview with a lady who had a company
that did accent reduction
and helped people
work on their english
and
on their english pronunciation because
it is a fact that uh in an
english-speaking country if you have a
strong
accent
that can be a disadvantage in the
workplace
so i'm going to talk a little bit about
what i consider to be the importance of
accent reduction and how we go about
doing it
first of all i think that in most
situations
it is far more important to speak well
to have a
broad vocabulary to have natural
phrasing
is much more important than the accent
unless you want to be a tv announcer or
something i know lots of people in
canada who are very competent who
communicate extremely well who give
presentations
and who use the language well but have
accents not necessarily a problem
normally people with poor act or unless
of course you're difficult to understand
and that's where sometimes people from
say south asia india
you know they're so
convinced they speak english so well and
they speak at rapid fire and it's
actually difficult to understand them
so as long as you're understandable
the question of accent reduction
is really a false problem
it's more a matter of the ability to
communicate effectively
so
accent reduction becomes more a matter
of vanity
than anything else so whether you are a
recent immigrant to canada wanting to
improve your accent in english or
whether you're learning a foreign
language we would all like to sound more
like the native speaker even though we
know we can't achieve it and there's
nothing wrong with that because after
all the native speaker is the model
of how the language is spoken so if we
model ourselves on the native speaker
when it comes to the phrasing and the
you know usage and so forth and so on
of course we would like to also model
ourselves
on the pronunciation of the native
speaker
there are those politically correct you
know sociolinguistic type you know
cultural sensitivity type people who
want to say well if you're hispanic then
you should keep your spanish accent
because that's
that represents who you are well fine if
that's what you want to do
uh but to me that doesn't make sense
then why don't you also
have you know if you're german or
japanese put all the verbs at the end of
the sentence why don't you imitate other
aspects or at least retain other aspects
of your language when you speak english
to me it doesn't make sense but
realistically most people are not going
to achieve native like pronunciation and
really it's not a problem so i kind of
have this contradictory view i think
it's not so important to sound like a
native
but it should be our goal even though we
know we're not going to achieve it
because it's part of the psychology
to learn to speak a language well i've
always said this its attitude is so
important you you almost think that you
become one of them i become chinese or
japanese or french i want to be like
them i indicate i imitate their gestures
i start thinking a little bit the way
they do so that's natural and the more
you can separate yourself from your own
culture
at least while you're speaking that
other language the better you're going
to do in all aspects of language
learning so why should you just hang on
to your accent as a sign of your
identity it doesn't make sense to me
now
how do we then
get rid of our accent
to me it's number one a matter of will
and i'll use an example when i was a
little child
my father could wiggle his ears and i
couldn't
and i sat by the television we had a
television i remember whenever i sat at
the television i would tell my brain
wiggle your ears and i don't know how
long i did this but i know that one day
if you can see
probably not very visible but i can
wiggle my ears in other words we can
will our brain to do things
so it's extremely important that you
want to
adopt
this other accent
uh so that's number one and you have to
think that you can do it the more
confident you are the more willing you
are like an actor many actors and
actresses are very good at imitating
other accents
because they're used to projecting
themselves into the role of someone else
so as a language learner you have to try
to project yourself into that role i am
now chinese
i'm not an english-speaking canadian
trying to learn chinese i am chinese i
can do it
so that's extremely important
in terms of the activities that we
should undertake i personally am not a
great believer in the international
phonetic
alphabet or
trying to focus on individual sounds and
where to put your tongue and all this
kind of stuff
i think it's difficult to remember those
things when we're speaking i mean there
are a few instructions like the french
i've heard the instruction that you go
ooh
and then try to say ee so if you go
come up with an uh
there's a few like that i mean in
english you stick your tongue between
your teeth to make the or think there's
a few like that but i don't think
there's so many there's not there's not
even 10 per language there's a few
crucial sounds in a language that might
be difficult and might be amenable to
that kind of explanation
similarly with the ipa because in every
language there are so many variations
uh within the language even amongst
people from the same area of the
language so
which of the forms of the native speaker
are you going to try to isolate with
this ipa
i think you're far better off and here's
where we come to that the key activity
is to listen
and you an immigrant to canada from
china in his 20s he'd been in canada for
three or four years his english was
flawless i thought he was born in canada
and what did he do he listened he
listened to a very limited amount of
content like i don't know 15 20 minutes
a thousand times a thousand times now
not many people have the discipline to
do that but that's what he did
i know in my chinese learning there was
some content that i loved i loved it
there were these comic dialogues i just
listened to them over and over and over
again even when i couldn't understand
them but it gave me the rhythm of the
language it worked on my brain and it
helped me in my pronunciation and
particularly it helped me with tones in
chinese so and i also recommend
listening at first to the language read
slowly because it's going to be easier
for the brain to identify the little
sound the difference differences in the
sounds so listen initially to a limited
amount of content read very slowly
and then start listening to the language
read at normal speed
and initially just listen
don't try to record yourself and compare
when you're not very good it's only
going to be
distraction interference and at some
point you start to speak and when you
start to speak you imitate and you and
when you imitate focus on imitating the
intonation
rather than the individual sounds if the
intonation if you can catch that
intonation it's almost like a pitchfork
in music if your brain can pick up that
intonation the music
other things are going to fall into
place
so to summarize
uh yes we obviously want to imitate the
accent the pronunciation of the native
speaker just as we imitate everything
about the native speaker and how he
handles his own language or her own
language number two most people are not
going to achieve native speaker
pronunciation and it doesn't matter as
long as they can be understood it is
more important to speak correctly using
normal usage that's number two number
three to get closer to native speaking
pronunciation you have to want to do it
you have to will it you have to be able
to see yourself project yourself in the
role of a native speaker of that
language and feel confident that you can
do it and fourth
the main activity is lots of listening
to a limited amount of content content
over and over initially read very slowly
give your brain a chance to pick out the
different sounds
and then
fast and i'm talking about a period of
six months maybe two months very slow
and four months faster and when you
start to speak
focus on the intonation and the rhythm
and don't worry so much about the
individual sounds there you have it
that's my take on pronunciation i got it
within the 10 minutes